so some of you might remember that last
week i said to you jokingly of course
when the world is complicated when i
need moral clarity and when i really
need to know what's taking place
geopolitically at such difficult times i
say to myself
what is tulsi gabbard's opinion
now that was a joke but the full joke is
actually i think
what would tulsi gabbard say but what
would televangelist pat robertson also
say and now we know uh pat robertson who
is now 91 years old of 700 club fame a
christian televangelist who has
previously said that so many things are
demonic i'm going to try to go from
memory here pat robertson has previously
said let me think now
yoga
harry potter
ouija boards
sometimes adopted children
sometimes second-hand sweaters
um
man what else all of these different
things can be demonic and have demons
attached to them so pat robertson
seemingly coming out of retirement to
explain why
russia has invaded ukraine and i have to
tell you i'm actually actually
fascinated by it um i really find this
type of stuff fascinating because he's
completely created an imaginary world
that he i guess believes exists with end
times and messages from god and
stuff about uh the pharisees or i don't
even know i'm gonna play it for you and
i i wish
i had i mean it's almost like a
child-like imagination that the guy has
check this out it is wild
here we go
putin's out of his mind yes maybe so but
at the same time he's propelled by god
he went into the ukraine
but that by the way uh pat robertson
still using the term the ukraine which
is just a signal of uh you know how long
he's been commenting on these things i
guess it wasn't his goal his goal
was to move against israel ultimately
and he will link up with turkey with
azerbaijan i mean with the
across the dardanelles in that little
bridge
and they will come together
and then you look down into
north sudan and you've got a muslim
country down there
and and there they all are persia of
course is iran and there is the land
that is set up in ezekiel 38 right you
see how
ukraine is key because of the you see
the land bridge between bulgaria greece
and turkey
and
all of that area is going to be
mobilized against israel in the latter
days and god says i am going to deal
with it now guys
understand when pat robertson says the
latter days
he's talking about a sort of apocalyptic
rapture end times when he when he says
latter days he means
the end as he believes to have been
biblically prophesied isn't this stuff
just fascinating so you can look at your
map you can read your newspapers you can
listen to your news but know of a fact
that god is bringing to pass what he
prophesied years ago through his servant
ezekiel now i i always it's always tough
for me to understand
do these christian extremist types
want the end times because like with
some of them from what i recall and i've
interviewed some of them as well it's
just so hard to keep track of all of it
i think some of them want the end times
because they believe that jesus comes
back then and again correct me if i'm
wrong everybody who's been good gets
eternal life with jesus or something
like they consider the rapture to be
good because the sinners are killed but
you want to usher in the end times i
think even though like most everybody
dies which you and i might be like well
that's bad sir uh but i think i think
people like pat robertson want the end
times
and you read it in the 39th 38th passage
of ezekiel 1 through 6. it's all there
and god is getting ready to do something
amazing and that will be fulfilled and
what putin is doing by moving as he is
to set up ukraine
as a
staging ground
for one of the armies and then across is
is erdogan at turkey and and you've got
between them that little dardanelles
area and it's going to happen so i just
say
that is what's coming up is putin crazy
is he mad well perhaps
but god says i'm going to put hooks in
your jaws and i'm going to draw you
into this battle whether you like it or
not and he's being compelled
after the move into the ukraine he's
being compelled to move again to get a
land bridge and then across the
dardanelles with turkey and watch what's
going to happen yeah now um i yeah as
many of you will notice pat robertson is
is not looking great but it still sounds
like the same old pat robertson with
some of those same same ideas so that
that is really wild i have to tell you
there's some weird way
in which i envy people who are able to
be so certain about things for which we
have no evidence and just allow
themselves to be completely absorbed
into that and and it sort of seems like
you don't have a care in the world in
the sense of
it's sort of like with the conspiracy
theorists everything is controlled it's
all predetermined it's all planned it's
just like it's gonna be what it is
there's something about being able to
fall for that that i almost envy because
it seems easier than realizing the
complexity
uh and uncertainty
of the world that we that we live in and
that hey we actually have an impact here
it's not just like well you know putin
it's all ordained by god putin's going
to do what he's going to do and that
that's really it it's been prophesied um
as as a practical matter
pat robertson's predictions aren't very
good um and just as one example here is
one where he said trump's going to win
and much like it was hard to tell
whether that last clip was an
endorsement of putin or a condemnation
of putin it's hard to tell whether this
clip is an endorsement of trump but he
was sure trump was going to win which he
didn't of course there's going to be a
war ezekiel 38 is going to be the next
thing by the way isn't he talking about
ezekiel 38 in both clips
the line hmm a time of peace
then
maybe the end but nobody knows the day
of the hour when the lord's going to
come back he said the angels don't know
it right and only the father knows it so
i'm not saying this is the second coming
but i am saying there are things that
people have thought it would be during a
millennial
time with the coming of jesus that are
going to happen in our lifetime
and
the next thing is the election that's
coming up in just a few weeks right at
which time
according to what i believe the lord
told me the president is going to be
re-elected i'm not i'm saying by all
means get out and vote vote for whoever
you want to vote for right by all means
let your voice be heard
but it's going to lead to civil diso
unrest of great proportion then a war
against israel and so forth and so on
yeah so you know the israel the
the lord getting back to israel didn't
happen trump didn't get reelected
uh but that is really something and he
has been predicting
end of the world stuff for a really long
time
in 1982
i wasn't even alive yet he predicted
that the judgment on the world was
coming very very soon
in uh 2006 he said the pacific northwest
would be devastated by a tsunami in 2007
he said mass killings would be unleashed
in america
uh i believe at one point he predicted
an asteroid and that didn't happen
either
uh
but okay i mean that it is what it is
and uh that's pat robertson's
perspective
and even with the trump thing it's like
okay so
is
is it good or bad if the end times come
you can't really tell from how he says
it he's like trump's going to win and
then there's going to be unrest and
we're going to get closer to the end
times but do you like that or do you not
like that it's never totally clear with
these guys
one of our sponsors is established
titles if you're looking for a perfect
last minute valentine's day gift check
this out it's funny it's unique and
they're supporting a great cause
established titles is a project based on
the historic scottish custom where
landowners are called lords and ladies
and so established titles lets you
ceremonially
buy as little as one square foot of
dedicated land in aberdeenshire scotland
so that you can call yourself a lord or
lady you get an official certificate
with a crest they let you see exactly
where your spot is located but in return
for each one sold established titles
will plant a tree to protect the
beautiful pristine woodlands of scotland
established titles also supports global
charities like one tree planted and
trees for the future so it's a fun gift
but you're also helping to support
something great and right now they're
having a huge valentine's day sale on
top of that you'll get an extra 10 off
when you go to establish titles dot com
slash pacman and use the code pacman the
link is down below